[Music]
[Applause]
he's the Hall of Famer sportscaster he's
Bob cus part of MLB Network's Prime n
countdown series returns tonight with
Bob as the host here and it runs all
week long uh ranking first baseman and
second baseman tonight at 5 and 530
Eastern MLB Network Bob thanks for
joining us if I talked to you a week ago
and I said you're the commissioner and
you could place Otani wherever you want
that's in the best interest of baseball
what would your answer have been I think
it's probably the answer they wound up
with it's probably the Dodgers now you
could say that the Yankees or the Mets
maybe New York gives him a little bit
more of a you know it's a larger market
numerically but you want him to be happy
you want him to thrive I think where
they were really holding their breath
and maybe it was just leverage from an
agent stand point but when there was
serious talk that the Blue Jays were in
the mix with all due respect to them and
their fans and the history of the
franchise it's nothing against them that
would have been bad for baseball overall
you just can't maximize the benefit to
baseball as an industry with SH Otani in
Toronto but you most certainly can uh
with the Dodgers they're always good
they're often disappointing in terms of
what happens in October but they're
always good there's an almost certainty
that you'll see him in the playoffs
maybe he gets deep into the playoffs uh
the team itself is a marquee team they
have a national following they have all
the resources to maximize this they're
one of the very few teams that can
advertize this investment and actually
make it profitable uh 700 million just
breaks the bank and breaks the previous
Paradigm everybody knows that uh
cumulatively about $300 million more
than anybody else has gotten but to use
the word that's been thrown around
around about him for years the guy's a
unicorn and so is this deal I'm trying
to understand the Angels you know you
lose him you don't get any compensation
a draft pick or whatever and you lose
him to the Angels or the Dodgers that's
a bad weekend Bob but we we could see
this happening you don't want to be the
GM or owner who traded away Otani but
you don't want to be the owner of GM who
didn't get anything for Otani when he
left you well when there was a lot of
talk about this the MLB Network at the
trade deadline of course and at that
point the Angels who seem to always
sadly disappoint they were only three or
four games out of the last wild card and
I thought that Ry Moreno and the front
office of the Angels actually kept Faith
with their fan base by saying a we're
going to keep him even if it's only for
two more months that you get to see this
once not in a lifetime but once in
Forever in the history of baseball
player and we're going to make an effort
therefore in the next couple of months
and Beyond to retain him now that effort
was unsuccessful the trapo opened on
them they plummeted to below 500 they
were not in the race but the day they
announced that they were not going to
put him on the trading block you may
remember this they had a double header
in Detroit a straight double head a
split and pitched a complete game shut
out or an eight inning one hit shutout
and then he hit two home runs as the DH
in the next game so at that point you
know Spirits are high around the angels
I can't blame them I feel bad I know
there are criticisms of every owner when
a team doesn't succeed but you think
about the angels with Mike Trout and
then they got pool and they got a good
player instead of a great player he was
a great player with the Cardinals what
they wound up was with a good player for
a while in the second half of his career
they they signed Josh Hamilton at that
point he was an MVP and he had personal
problems and the the trapo opened on him
as well they had Otani for a while and
couldn't get to the postseason with OT
and trout both you can't say they didn't
try I mean the renon signing he comes
off a a world series title and big RBI
numbers with the Nats and doesn't do the
same with the angels it feels like the
whole franchise is snake pit I'm
wondering otani's impact on the game 10
years 15 years down the road where are
team's going to be encouraging or not
discouraging your pitcher from being a
hitter or vice versa college players
what kind of impact do you think Otani
will have that way yeah I can't say
precisely Dan but there's going to be
some obviously there's going to be some
and you know uh that the best player in
high school always pitches and plays
some position and you get a little bit
of that in college and then of course
they're channeled into whatever they uh
the scouts think is their best position
or their college coaches thinks uh is
their best position but the best players
the most gifted players at least start
out being many of them pitchers and
position players and some of them
inspired by Otani are going to want to
try that we're talking to Bob cus Hall
of Fame sportscaster MLB Network host
are we changing requirements on the Hall
of Fame like we do with the NFL where
running backs are diminished wide
receivers getting more receptions and
yards and guys getting more sacks and
quarterbacks getting bigger numbers what
is baseball's uh sort line of
demarcation has anything really changed
in the last you know 5 to seven
years I think analytics play a greater
part in it because the younger members
of the baseball writers association who
qualify having been there for 10 years
as you know Dan it's only the writers
who vote broadcasters don't but the
younger guys are more dependent on
analytics and even the older guys have
kind of caught up with that so they may
see some players through a different
prism that's the reason why you look at
Bobby Abu and somebody says you know
what I can compare Bobby Abu to Al Kine
who back in the day was a noou Hall of
Famer and you're look at a Bobby and
scratching your head but maybe analytics
say that you should at least consider
him so that's part of it but then you
know we've been over this before
everybody's got to make their own
decision about the steroid era if you're
going on pure numbers Maguire Sosa Von
certainly Clemens aod they're all in
already Manny Ramirez all in already how
do you parts that especially in light of
the fact that it's reasonable to assume
that some guys even if they didn't
testify before Congress or you don't
have hard evidence that some guys
already in at least dabbled in steroids
during that period of time do you think
we ever get to the point where we
go you know younger voters they just say
you know what steroids not a big deal to
me and we're going to put all these guys
in I I think there's some
sentiment in that direction there's
still a lot of hardliner who say no and
there's a handful and I might be among
them if I was a writer who say I'm going
to put bonds and Clemens in a different
category because I can rationalize that
had they retired before the turn of the
century they would have been in on their
natural merits but I can't say the same
for Maguire and Sosa there's a school of
thought that goes that way but with each
passing year it seems that the hard line
resistance to steroid guys uh lessons
and part of it is the writers who sayou
know what I just throw my hands up I get
it I get that a lot of these
performances are not fully authentic I
get that we're comparing apples to
oranges but I just can't figure out how
to deal with it so the heck with it
everybody in whose numbers indicate
they're going to get in it's like Lance
Armstrong he was the best at
cheating yes I mean bonds was the best
if you said everybody gets to use
steroids that guy is so much better than
everybody else and and maybe Clem no
doubt but but Lance was so good in a
sport so dirty I'm like um
yes I don't know the example of that is
that whether it's the tour to France I
mean I'm not an expert on cycling but
the various other events I guess the
tour to France and the Olympics would be
the two uh most prestigious ones they
don't award the prize to whoever
finished second behind Lance Armstrong
because they figure at least one through
25 were also on some kind of
PS what would they do some some guy out
for his morning cycle oh you on the side
of the road you're clean here take this
yeah you the with the Schwin bicycle uh
you get to you win you won the next
stage I really I didn't even yeah you
win we're you're the only guy clean uh
who's the how does this Otani deal
affect future free agents like Juan SoDo
can does it
affect it probably does a little bit but
I said this on Saturday when the news
broke on mlbn every GM in baseball is
now rehearsing the following speech to
that star player and his agent this is a
high tide that raises no other votes
because this guy is completely unique
and so is the Dodgers circumstance so
this doesn't take a 30 million guy to 40
it doesn't even take an 8 million guy to
12 he's completely unique nobody else
compare yourself to judge compare
yourself if you're a pitcher to sherer's
deal or Verlander's deal but this stands
completely alone and I don't want to
hear about it I don't know if that
arguments is going to carry the day or
somebody will break ranks uh and move
the next great player not to otani's
level but beyond judge's level you know
beyond Trout's level and Harper's level
and into the 50s or 60s maybe but I
think by and large you could make a
reasonable argument that Otani is in a
category of his own and so the the
conversation does not include him when
we come to the next guy were you ever
broached about being a GM of a team no
no no no and neither was neither was I
ever broached despite all the talk about
being commissioner of baseball and I
always said I'm I'm neither interested
nor qualified don't forget
it but but don't be humble on
this you could have been commissioner
you could have been a a really good
commissioner I might have been a
commissioner than a GF know I really
don't I really don't think I really
don't think honestly that I was
qualified because there are aspects of
it uh grasp of economics and especially
all the back room wheeling and dealing
and twisting of arms you have to have a
certain kind of temperament for that and
and I don't and I I always the analogy I
always used was if you think a
particular columnist is astute
politically that doesn't necessarily
mean you think he or she should run for
president or be Supreme Court Justice
their role is to offer thoughts and
people weigh it for whatever it's worth
and I was a commentator about baseball
not just calling games but about the
state of the game I even wrote a book
about it and if people appreciated that
well that was my
contribution well the press conferences
would have sounded so much better if you
were the
commissioner I'll I'll grant you that
okay good all right fair enough uh Bob
great to talk to you thanks for joining
us all right Dan one more thing yeah I
had nothing to do with the rankings when
people watch Prime n I didn't even know
what the rankings were until they handed
me the script and there are some of
these rankings and exclusions that I
don't agree with so don't blame me
you're distancing yourself when I when I
hosted Sports sentury people were mad
when Secretariat got in there I go I
didn't vote for the horse but well
believe me when when I found out
Secretariat was roughly at the same
level of ranking as Mickey mle I wanted
to strangle you and I knew it wasn't
your fault but you were the guy whose
name
I know I had people mad at me uh thank
you Bob see you Bob C Hall of Famer MLB
Network and host of prime n yeah